it's amazing that everyone came together  in this situation to learn that all the  passengers had no idea who each other  were but literally we're taking jackets  and shirts off their back to give to  strangers letting you know women and  babies out first and sacrificing their  own livelihood for complete strangers is  so inspiring so incredible a glad that  there's so many heroic men and women  more flying planes in this country who  really know what they do of trouble  ensues gives me hope that human beings  do come together and you know there's  there's a bond in a unity and all of us  that sometimes goes unnoticed but it's  kind of brought it up I won't be able to  leave the theater saying what's my Sully  moment what's my first responder moment  what's the position where I can put  myself to go rescue we have the capacity  within us and I want to see the world  light up with heroes across the board